una biopsia mamaria se realiza para
determinar si un bulto o área
sospechosos en las mamas son cancerosos
en este procedimiento se extrae una
muestra del tejido sospechoso para que
se pueda examinar en un laboratorio las
biopsias mamarias se practican
utilizando una de cuatro técnicas
biopsia por punción que se puede
realizar como un procedimiento en el
consultorio biopsia estereotáxica que se
realiza siguiendo la guía de la
mamografía biopsia percutánea guiada por
ultrasonido y biopsia quirúrgica
realizada en la sala de operaciones
si su médico puede palpar el bulto
generalmente realizará una biopsia por
punción que puede ser una aspiración de
quiste mamario una biopsia por
aspiración con aguja fina o una biopsia
percutánea en cada procedimiento se
insertará una aguja en la mama para
extraer fluido o una muestra del tejido
si el bulto mamario no se puede palpar y
solo se ve en una mamografía o
ultrasonido su médico puede recomendarle
una biopsia percutánea en guiada por
ultrasonido o una biopsia estereotáxica
para una biopsia estereotáxica usted se
recuesta boca abajo en una camilla que
deja la mama visible a través de un
orificio en la camilla guiado por una
mamografía generada por computadora del
área sospechosa su médico insertará una
aguja hueca en la masa de la mama y
extraerá varios cilindros pequeños de
tejido para su examen
las biopsias percutáneas guiadas por
ultrasonido se llevan a cabo cuando se
detecta un bulto mamario a través del
ultrasonido en este procedimiento su
médico utilizará una sonda de
ultrasonido para ubicar la masa y una
aguja hueca para extraer varios núcleos
del tejido en las biopsias percutáneas
guiadas por ultrasonido y estereotáxica
se extrae una muestra pequeña de tejido
con una aguja sin embargo si no se puede
acceder al área sospechosa detectada en
la mamografía o ultrasonido mediante una
biopsia percutánea o si su médico quiere
extraer toda el área puede recomendar
una biopsia quirúrgica
la cirugía mamaria se lleva a cabo en
una sala de operaciones utilizando dos
técnicas localización con aguja y
biopsia excepcional para la localización
con aguja se insertarán una aguja y un
hilo de metal en la mama guiados por el
ultrasonido o la mamografía para marcar
la ubicación del área sospechosa el
cirujano realizará una incisión en la
mama en la zona donde se encuentra el
hilo de metal y extirpar a el área
deseada aunque pueda palpar el bulto
mamario su médico puede recomendar
extirpar lo por completo en lugar de
tomar una muestra como una aguja una vez
más su médico realizará una incisión en
la mama y extirpar a la masa completa
generalmente los cirujanos también
extirparan una cantidad pequeña de
tejido sano de alrededor de la masa
durante estos procedimientos las
biopsias quirúrgicas se pueden realizar
con anestesia general o local debe
hablar con su cirujano sobre el tipo de
anestesia que va a recibir dado que las
biopsias mamarias se llevan a cabo como
paciente externa podrá regresar a su
hogar después del procedimiento